dicen que derribó hasta 40 aviones
enemigos una hazaña absolutamente
increíble dada la superioridad de la
Fuerza Aérea rusa sobre la de Ucrania el
mito del supuesto haz de la Aviación
ucraniana llamado El fantasma de gif
tuvo en expectativa a miles de personas
en las redes sociales muchos decían que
el fantasma de kiev era nada más y nada
menos que el mayor este pantalábalca de
29 años por lo que varias fotografías
suyas comenzaron a circular en las
diferentes redes sociales Hasta que el
comando de la fuerza aérea de Ucrania
advirtió a través de su cuenta en la red
social Facebook que el fantasma de gif
era una leyenda creada por los propios
ucranianos El Comando reitero también
sobre la necesidad de comprobar las
fuentes de información y también afirmó
que tarahualca no era el heroico piloto
y que mucho menos había derribado 40
aviones rusos